Danish sounds strange.
Like a throat lick.
As if Danes are holding a cough back.
Or maybe a potato is stuck in their necks
Obviously ... that's what everyone is telling me.
But why?
Why does Danish sound so fun to people?
I have recently discovered how Swedes, Norwegians and Danes can all communicate without
to change language.
But this was not fair and uniform - some languages ​​were easier to understand than others.
The Internet eagerly pointed its finger in one language in particular: Danish.
I submit a video and are told that Danish is a joke.
I log on to social media and read about the potato in their neck.
I visit a discussion forum and it's a "stray goose".
A study tells me that Swedish children regard Danish as being uglier and more strange than Danes consider Swedish.
Of course, some of it is "crazy" and "good-natured teasing".
But even though I take it all with a spruce salt-marinated herring, I still have to ask: What makes Danish
Sounds ridiculous?
Maybe I could add my own theory.
I blame the Danish butter for their pastries.
But no, this is NativLang, so you already know what we need to do: sift
The story of the Danish language, to uncover what exactly makes this language's pronunciation stand out.
So Danish is notoriously difficult to learn to pronounce.
You will hear me try, but will someone be so sweet to back me up.
Red porridge with cream.
Well, okay!
Let's travel back in time that was once 1300 years ago:
Denmark spoke an Indo-European Germanic language with a special Nordic touch,
as we call Old Norse.
For them, it was the "Danish tongue", the Danish tongue (the Danish language).
Everywhere in Scandinavia it is a time of unity.
Wherever you go, Nordic sounds like Nordic.
But soon these Danish tongues will be left unresolved and will be upgraded to Viking status.
During the Viking Age, something will change.
It starts in Denmark.
A Dane, probably many Danes, but at least this one, decides "I will pronounce my vowels
differently ", which leads to the fact that eastern Nordic differs from the western Danish.
It's the start of a trend, the perfect setup for the rest of our story: Hey, everyone
there was another sound change in Dnamark.
At this point, over a thousand years ago, we can officially call it "Denmark",
the borderlands of the Danes.
See! This rune stone says it.
The Vikings settle down.
The Middle Ages settle down.
At this time, Scandinavia is a continuum of dialects, which can easily trace their origins
to the east and west.
Oh and it too often forgot Old Guns on its own island, where vowels at times
neither corresponded to western or eastern nordic
Officially, however, this is a Latin era.
Not very much written Nordic.
Until Denmark begins to behave medieval and write down the Skåne law.
Thanks to printers who copied it, this law is available in several editions, including this cool
edition in runes.
Its words show another Danish change: pressure-weak vowels are weakened.
That is the reason why the well-known endings of Swedes and Norwegian all
Danish becomes / ə /, / ə /, / ə /!
Meanwhile, the Hanseatic League unites itself to dominate the continent's northern coast,
which leads to a war and many new words from medieval German.
Or Mittelniederdeutsch.
Ha.
Meanwhile, another change is taking place in Denmark: consonants become softer,
whereby [t] softens to [ð] i / matr / to food.
This is lenition.
It's a normal change (just ask Spanish), but strangely enough, Danes do it at the end of syllables.
Consonants and depressed vowels become weakened, but pressure-enhancing vowels multiply.
When counting, Danish ends up with more distinct vowels than, possibly, some other language.
So this is a Danish that gets different.
We are on the trail of something.
But on the "sounds ridiculous" scale, so far I will count on being a "chatterer".
So far.
It's 1526.
A Swede writes that Danes sound "as if they are about to cough," turns words into theirs
throat "," twists and twists them ".
What is this hoax?
Will not know it for the next two centuries, after which a Danish grammar writes in
Concordia res parve crescunt ... (Second Test of Danish Orthography).
(Hey, at least my Latin works - besides, it's a bold title).
Well, this book describes how Danes pronounce many syllables with "a very little hiccup".
A little hiccup with a bold name, a "shock".
The shock to the neck is not one sound.
It sums up a whole process.
A complicated process with many phases and a lot of anatomy that happens in your neck.
But it is also not on every syllable.
These do not have: "tear", "do".
But these have: "wounds", "die".
It has been called creaking, cough-like and let's not forget, a constant stream of very small hiccups.
And it is crucial if you ever want to master the real Danish accent.
At the same time, as this author writes about hiccups, another sound change takes place in Denmark.
For once, however, it is not Danish's fault.
Danish had retained a rolling Nordic "R". But a new "R" spreads through France and Germany,
a dramatic change that deserves its own story, the so-called "scar-r" (throat-R). Instead of a tongue tip,
rolled / r / is it a rear-in-mouth / ʁ /.
Denmark got a bad case of this creep, whose symptoms include changing words like / reddish /.
To, uh, this: red porridge.
The result is an even more high Danish.
We're almost there.
Almost, because they have all the right sounds ... in Copenhagen.
But Scandinavia is a rich mosaic of dialects.
Sweden wants to keep its many variants, including a prehistoric form of gutnisk.
In Norway, there is still no single spoken Norwegian.
But back in Denmark, the old dialects, some of which have never had bumps, will attend
one last change: the traditional dialects will mostly disappear.
We end up with almost all of Denmark speaking one language, a language with the simplest
grammatical endings in Scandinavia, weakened consonants, perhaps the largest number
vowels in the world and small hiccups / / s.
And this is how the Danes went from speaking Nordic so well to everyone else to sound
incredibly strange.
Or oddly incredible.
Stay tuned and subscribe to languages.